as someone who lives with his own grief
i also know that what often matters most
to the bereaved is that those we have
lost
are not forgotten
prince william is reflecting on the
death of his mother princess diana there
is comfort in
remembering in acknowledging that
while taken
horribly soon
they lived
they changed our lives
with his wife kate middleton by his side
william made a speech at the opening of
the manchester arena memorial it's a
tribute to the 22 people who died after
a bombing at the ariana grande concert
in 2017. for catherine and i
it is very important that we are with
you here today
to remember the 22 lives so brutally
taken
to acknowledge the hundreds of lives
that were irrevocably changed
and to pay tribute to the resilience of
this great city
the duke of cambridge then opens up
about his own experience with grief
something he knows all too well after
losing his mom you'll recall princess
diana was killed in a car crash in 1997
william was just 15 years old at the
time i know that the pain and the trauma
felt by many has not gone away
as someone who lives with his own grief
i also know that what often matters most
to the bereaved is that those we have
lost
are not forgotten
there is comfort in remembering
in acknowledging that
while taken
horribly soon
they lived
they changed our lives
both william and his brother prince
harry have been reflecting on their
mom's life a lot lately just last month
harry opened up to today's hoda copy
about how he keeps diana's memory alive
with his own kids do you tell archie
he's old enough about your mom
yes yeah yeah very much so i didn't
tell him all the stuff that happened but
suddenly that this is you know grandma
diana and we got a couple of photos up
in the house in these moments do you
ever feel your mom's presence yeah no um
for me um it's constant it has been over
the last two years more so than ever
before
um it's almost as though she's
done her
done her bit with my with my brother and
now she's very much like helping me
the brothers who've had a rocky
relationship since 2020 when harry and
his wife meghan markle stepped down as
working members of the royal family
might be mending things soon it turns
out harry wants to sort things out with
william ahead of their grandmother queen
elizabeth's platinum jubilee
celebrations this summer all with the
help of a mediator harry i'm told
suggested perhaps that they might get
some sort of a mediator in on these
talks to make some progress it was
something that he has suggested to his
father he's made it very clear that he
he wants to sort things out he wants
things to be improved don't forget when
william had a party over here last year
to thank those who'd been involved with
the diana statue he didn't actually
invite harry to that he didn't ask him
to come back over from the states for it
so i think that gives you some
indication as to how tense and how
difficult that relationship is and that
may well be why harry suggested to his
father that they may need some something
of a mediator in all of this because the
sticky relationship here the one that's
much harder to get back on an even track
is william and harry's
[Music]
you